Hi there, I'm Jennifer Murphy and welcome to "Let's Move It."
I'm here with Dr. Michael Roizen from Cleveland Clinic.
Hey, Doctor.
And you're moving it every day?
You're gonna run a marathon, is that right?
This is true.
I am moving it every day, but the problem is Christian from Beachwood is not.
He sits at his desk every day...
...and he wants to know what can he do to burn some calories while at work.
One, Christian, don't fall asleep.
Your brain uses about 25% of your energy but you have to be awake.
It really decreases when you fall asleep.
We caught you at your desk the other day, so stay awake.
Second thing is do walking meetings.
If you ever have a meeting, don't do it at a desk or a table.
Walk around.
Third is go to the farthest bathroom every time you have to get up.
Don't use the nearby one.
Pass that by, go to the farther bathroom.
Anything you can do to move, but especially stay awake, is great.